il ya beaucoup de choses qui relèvent de
l'anomalie lorsqu'on constate dans les
baromètres de popularité figaro magazine
alain juppé est de très loin la première
presse personnalité dans les rangs des
républicains aux yeux des français
globalement et des républicains ce qui
n'est tout à fait singulier compte tenu
de la défaite cinglante et quasi
humiliante qu'il a essuyées lors de la
primaire donc il reste une valeur sûre
qui peut être fait un peu contrepoids ou
contrepoint avec les l'image d'emmanuel
macro d'ailleurs quand on voit les
personnalités qui sont ici prise et on
voit bien comment chacun constitue une
sorte d'abord par rapport à peut-être
des cases qui sont un petit moment quand
c'est vrai qu'il y manque d'une très
forte personnalité d'un gouvernement
juppé il doit franchir le pont pas
finalement on dit je fasse je suis pas
sûr report emmanuel macron l'arrivée du
gp serait forcément une bonne chose
alain juppé il a une bonne image
pourquoi parce qu'il incarne le
le vieux sage d'une certaine manière
donc
mais de l'intégrer dans un gouvernement
ça fait quand même un retour à l'ancien
monde alors que c'est exactement
l'inversé que veut faire mieux le
maquereau donc je la sais je suis pas
sûr de gagner en répondant aussi à votre
question c'est pas non plus l'intérêt
d'alain juppé intérêts d'alain juppé
s'est pas de redevenir misé tamise de
six ça et ça sont intéressés c'est de
devenir un personnage à l'ats jacques
delors ou enfin intéressant l'intérêt
pour macron c'est que ça continue de
mettre le bazar ch jeux d'eau
républicain de ce point de vue là pour
lui c'est plutôt une bonne chose
oui par exemple
oui oui mais enfin ce n'est pas inutile
d'avoir un petit électroménager brockman
ambiguïté à limite ça s'arrange non mais
je pense que même juppé de vue sa vie
parce que je n'ai pas envie d'être un
nouveau ministre il a peut-être min sous
les ordres de voir filippi se voit pas
remise
je pense que il ne s'imagine pas ça en
revanche un destin européen
pourquoi pas ça ça peut l'intéresser et
d'ailleurs quand il commence à parler du
grand corps central fin du grand il dit
pas on dit palin dit pas liste enfin on
comprend quand même l'idée de s'entendre
avec les maquereaux nice aux européennes
on se dit qu'il a peut-être ensuite eu
une idée derrière la tête ça oui ça
c'est possible